I wish we had recorded what we were
talking about in the studio earlier that
[__] was crazy it was funny that would
have been the best but I know for Pearl
strong producers but
um but yeah I mean that that's kind of
what I mean that's kind of what's going
on there right so this is what I'm
talking about is like the game this is
why you know getting your money right so
important but it's not the only thing
but it's a very important thing because
like there's two modes guys go into
money mode and then they go into girl
mode right and so it it's very very rare
when I meet a guy that they can get
their money and their thing and they're
and they're scaling it pretty decently
yeah that's right because I mean I
wasted most of my 20s in a you know
pointless uh you know promiscuous sort
of haze of you know nonsense and I mean
I wouldn't yeah
but I'm still going yeah
what's changed Troy the party's still
rocking
you're just miserable inside
according to the Chad God yeah yeah I
know yeah yeah exactly no but um what
was it gonna say
um yeah I would recommend guys do that I
think you know the money muscle muscle's
gay whatever thing is is absolutely 100
true and I think in the manager now it's
much more promoted because back in the
day when I was you know when you you
know when I was when I was like young
and innocent or whatever when the game
stuff started coming out it was it was
basically like right learn this thing
called game right don't bother about
value doesn't matter if you learn this
thing called game and you go and do it
you know go to the go to the club say
these lines do do these different
routines and stuff you'll get the girls
and then people realize well hang on to
me that's nonsense you need to have the
value as well and that's why we've had
people like the Tates and Justin Waller
and you know all of these dudes who are
like no you you know you've got to get
sterling sterling yeah absolutely yeah I
think some people like it's like the
procrastination yeah they're like oh
yeah I gotta do this then I gotta do
that yeah they don't want to fail so
they just keep saying they're going to
do other [__] exactly and I totally
agree with the with the self-improvement
message I think it's 100 right yeah you
should but you should it has to be done
as you're on your way
21 but he's in his 40s Troy found the
Fountain of Youth yeah
yeah it's a fountain of Botox actually
yeah
he's right so guys will think right okay
so I've got to get the value yeah I've
got to get the money I've got to get the
muscles and all that which is great but
if you're not practicing your rears then
you're still going to be the dork in the
club you know what I'm saying right
because when you think of all these guys
when you think about you think about
Sterling you think about the Tate you
think about Joe Waller they've all got
they've always something about them
haven't they do you know what I'm saying
it's not yeah they got the money they
got the looks and stuff but it's also
they've got that thing you know and
you've got to have that thing like an
aura like an aura again yeah yeah they
have a presence exactly a presence yeah
and whether it's like because I know
everyone this is like kind of roller
thing along with a couple other people
from the red pill but it's this whole
thing of like you have to dress in this
outfit or you have to have like your
dress everyone's in a costume every we
all have these masks on and stuff like
it's like business mode party mode and
stuff like that right so they're really
well suit game versus like dressing like
a hip-hop cut it just all depends on
what you're going after like I mean like
fresh she's like yeah yeah I mean I'm
going to this kind of Club I want to be
blinged the [__] out and [__] yeah like
a boogie with the hoodie had the
shiniest diamond necklace I've ever seen
in my [__] life I'm so I'm so like
mesmerized by it today yeah but like it
was like imagine like like um he's a
good dude actually and so we met him at
the uh rolling loud and stuff last year
but he had like the clear like I've
never seen diamonds like it was like
like you would look at it and it would
like draw you in like I've seen a lot of
diamonds and like those [__] was crazy
so I don't know that's a big change but
like that's what I'm talking about is so
it's kind of like I mean so what do you
tell guys depending like when guys are
coming up to you and stuff is like I
want this because are you just showing
them how to get up to girls are you
showing them these these hey man that's
the kind of girls they kind of want to
go after you give them advice internally
you probably need to dress this way yeah
we talk about style as well actually and
what we've done just recently we filmed
some content with a tailor in London who
I go to James Tusk goes to him as well
he's really good guy he's got like a you
know great great sort of setup over in
London and um this isn't a massive plug
necessarily but we're doing some
packages with that guy who could do
online consultations and stuff like that
because because getting your look right
and I can't talk because I've just
jumped off a plane basically but I mean
generally speaking getting your look
right that's that is super important but
again you know these are all all of
these things are great but if you don't
have and there is side of things or
whatever you want to call it is so
important it's so key and and that is
the key thing that guys guys kind of
need to learn speaking of getting your
look right
[Music]
[Laughter]
show the camera
[Music]
Treat Me Like a Stranger
there you are and we're back I should go
on the strip tonight and see how let's
see how effects no whenever anyone asks
me and I'm like they're like oh like why
does it say that I'm like we can't even
pick boyfriends how the hell are we
supposed to pick the leader of the Free
World they love that just they just use
that line exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
so come on
right like you know I know you're blown
up and stuff like you I bet you still
have a lot of your like some friends and
stuff from back in the day and stuff
like are they asking you for like advice
in terms of because they see like I mean
you're running you're running basically
kind of a dating Channel sort of like
dating advice and stuff channel are they
asking you for advice in terms of their
stuff
um
I'm trying to thank friends back in the
day because I know you tell me about the
volleyball well I mean to be fair a
decent amount we're feminists they
weren't that happy with me well
sometimes when you you know become
really successful at something as well
people know you from before and so
they're like sometimes less likely to be
like oh you know I want that information
it's some you know it's it's interesting
because what we do you know with our
families and stuff is we teach people
about crypto yeah but with as much we as
we know about crypto you would think
there would be other people you know
seeing how much we made and all that
stuff and be like I want to do that
but then they don't so they don't might
not have the right motivation either so
you know yeah no I mean to be honest
it's lonely when you get pretty big
especially with women it's like ruthless
oh my gosh but yeah I I would say
there's a couple but I don't have like a
ton of friends from back in the day
right do people distance themselves
because of them well I had one make a
video about me really oh yeah she
totally did sure yeah it's like well how
long was it was like yeah it was like a
tick tock help yeah no but she was
making all these Tick Tock so it's kind
of like yeah yeah my boys Pearl survives
so many cancellation sticks a strong
person to get through that yeah I know
it's crazy all right so Pearl it's time
to get your candles all right why
shouldn't tell me right now why should P
why should people take away the ability
well let's see why should women
shouldn't vote tell me why oh because I
figured out as the root of all evil
no seriously when I because I basically
just started looking well first okay the
rabbit hole started when I started
reading the anti-suffragist writings so
there was the suffragettes which they
try to label the suffragettes as like
these reasonable women that just wanted
to give Women rights gen ones gen ones
yeah they weren't they were terrorists
they they funded terrorist attacks they
tried to do assassinations like these
were not nice women and the
anti-suffragettes had more support than
the suffragette so the anti-women voting
and I was like well why wouldn't they
want to vote their writings said this is
the beginning of them destroying the
family unit you're supposed to the
Natural order of the world is supposed
to be God men women you're supposed to
submit to your husband that is the only
way things work like in everything I
started to realize like when women we
are our greatest selves like the mothers
that are actually like good wives good
Mothers like the men can't compete with
that you know it's like they're they're
it's like Beauty full but it's like when
we go on our own it's chaos we become
[__]
yeah
women under 35 are on only fans right 90
of us have been on birth control the
average body count is between five and
eight and all the men say we're lying so
we probably are and and I was like I was
just reading all these numbers like the
more choice that we get the worse we
choose I'm like oh we're just dummies
and then I looked into propaganda and I
realized
um in the early 1900s they figured out
proper like what propaganda is and
basically they they figured out you can
show the women some sad story of a 12
year old chick that can't get an
abortion and we just run to the polls
we're like oh no save the 12 year old
rape victim let me run to the polls even
though the men are logical they're like
that doesn't happen off you know yeah
but and so that started in the 1900s and
so then I was like huh why are there all
these policies that actively
discriminate against men like why are
there like why are they able to say
Andrew Tate's a human trafficker why can
I divorce rape a guy like why why don't
men get access to their kids and it's
because all none of the politicians can
get elected without pandering to women
so there's no incentive for anything to
change and when I figured this out I was
like we got to take that [__] away we've
gotten so out of pocket then I figured
out then I figured out I was like wait
we just live life on easy mode the only
reason any of us make money normally is
just because we're hot and young and I
was like
um and all the industries we take over
like Education Health Care suck right
whenever we get into management biggest
horse in nursing yeah whenever we get
into management they always just fire us
or we run the company into the ground
and I was like wait so literally like
men do 45 percent of men do
infrastructure jobs so that means
Trucking I mean it's an expanded
definition a little bit bit but we added
in trucking we added in like buses we
added in plumbers like and so it's like
half of men are doing that we're only
seven six percent of women are and I'm
like how is it fair and we're a net
taxpayer loss so we spend more than we
make so I'm like wait the men are paying
all the money they're doing all the hard
jobs and as a thank you we discriminate
against I'm like we're out of pocket we
have been too spoiled we gotta take this
[__] away immediately
and all the college debt as well now
yes men are going to college and they
teach you in college to meet two men I
remember this because oh my God they
totally do wow they totally do they
totally everywhere well I I don't know I
didn't go to school here but but I've
I've heard women like like um use terms
that I don't know where else they would
have got from so like it for example
like sociological studies well well
sociology was like made up anyways yeah
yeah psychology but yeah I remember in
college we would go we had this like um
thing that we like I don't know what it
was for I think it was to play in sports
like I just remember I had to go to this
meeting and they basically were like if
you say no before sex and then like he
basically the man's pushy all right
their guys are like car salesmen come on
please
[Laughter]
and it's like you really didn't want to
buy it but the salesman just wouldn't
let it go basically they said if a guy
does that it's rape yeah and it's
because they switched they switched the
and this is what women do we go into
these industries and then we're like we
don't like your tone and let's change
the meanings of words and they take
these words that have meant the same
thing for a hundred years like what was
rape it used to be I pulled a chick off
the side of the road and she was
screaming and crying yeah forced and it
was it I forgot the exact definition but
it was like forced carnal or carp or
something yeah but but it's basically
for sex and they switched it to sex
without consent but consent is
subjective I'm not a guy who literally
thought he raped a chick because like
she was like grinding on him or like
like in bed and then she said no and I
was I don't know some weird stuff but
I'm like that's not the same thing he
was running well she was like in his bed
and I I don't that but I was like
this is like rape right well I feel like
responsibility if you're in some dude's
bed what do you think yeah these Zoomers
are [__] and then and then on top of
that they had it in more they added new
words too they add in these like new
words that nobody knows what they mean
yeah coercion yeah coercion sexual
assault and and they teach you this
stuff in these like classes
before being innocent and women are
dummies like we're all idiots